yo ble C podcast man special guest in
here go watch our full interview it's
out uh but let's get to this freestyle
cuz she's one of my favorite new rappers
killing it out of the Bronx right now
scar lip is here welcome thank you for
having me Kev of course and you brought
uh you know we like to like let y'all
pick the beats and I love this beat that
you picked today let's get in uh some
some Bronx flavor over some boozy [__]
how about that shout out to boozy let's
do it let's do it come
on
[Music]
ever since my mom died something in me
change seeing her body in the casket
trigger something in my brain when you
hurt you call your mom so me and you was
not the same so don't say you understand
cuz you do not feel my pain all I think
about is violence my anger I can't
contain I'm paranoid can't even be on a
ship without thinking it's about the
sink it was a hit and run and for that
you took her life did you know she was a
mother a daughter or a wife you took
from me so now I got to take from you
kidnap your daughter knock your door
down and we taking you my [__] begging
me to kill you but then I start to think
is the love really genuine or is it
really fake all these [__] say they
won't fold but that pressure make them
break so God keep his angels with me cuz
I don't trust these [__] please God
let my mama rest in peace and we going
to find her
killer yeah yeah we going to find these
[__] creep and we run and we creep and
we ride
and we creep and we ride and we creep
and we ride come
on man come on scar lip come on man woo
that was hard thank you hey appreciate
you guys watching this free style we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com
promo code bootleg when you check out
you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG